esta es una imagen de pantalla de la
sección de ejercicios de khan academy
nos dice más son está parado en el
quinto escalón de una escalera vertical
la escalera tiene 15 escalones y la
diferencia de altura entre escalones
consecutivos es de medio metro él está
pensando si sube baja o se queda quieto
vamos a dibujar la escalera en la que
está parado masón es una escalera
vertical y tiene 15 escalones vamos a
dibujar aquí la escalera y trataremos de
dibujar los 15 escalones más o menos
iguales 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
y 15
la diferencia entre estos escalones es
de medio metro 0.5 metros y nos dicen
que más son está en el quinto escalón
uno dos tres cuatro cinco aquí es donde
se encuentra
digamos que hdn denota la altura por
encima del nivel del suelo de los pies
de masón medido en metros después de
moverse en escalones sin más son bajar
escalones n es negativa bueno para
comprender bien esto vamos a analizar
cuál será cuánto será h de 0 pues
significa que masón ha subido 0
escalones es decir no se ha movido aun
cuando no suba o baje escalones más
conseguirán el quinto escalón
así que qué tan alto está bueno
suponiendo que está a punto cinco metros
del suelo el primer escalón tendremos
uno dos tres cuatro cinco escalones
arriba y cada uno mide medio metro cinco
por 0.5 va a ser igual a 2.5 metros así
que h de cero es igual a 2.5 metros h de
1 significa que más son subió un escalón
es igual a 1 así que h de uno va a ser
medio metro más alto por lo que será
igual a tres metros y podemos seguir
haciendo esto para varias entradas pero
bueno vamos a responder a la pregunta
que nos hacen cuál tipo de número es más
apropiado para el dominio de la función
recordemos que el dominio es el conjunto
de valores de entrada válidos para los
que está definida la función n es
nuestra entrada y es el número de
escalones que más son sube o baja por lo
que no podemos tener una fracción de
escalón pues no podemos dejar flotando
el pie en el aire así que tendremos
números enteros para los escalones serán
positivos cuando el suba y negativos
cuando él baje y cero si no se mueve los
números reales no nos sirven porque él
no puede subir y escalones o puntos
cinco escalones ya que no puede dejar el
pie en el aire así que nuestro dominio
será de los números enteros y no los
números reales
solo puedo poner números enteros como
entradas e incluso no son todos los
números enteros posibles pues no se
puede bajar más de cinco escalones
porque llegamos al suelo y tampoco se
puede subir una cantidad arbitraria de
escalones hacia arriba pues porque se
acaba la escalera entonces nuestro
dominio será un subconjunto de números
enteros también nos piden el intervalo
del dominio tenemos aquí estos controles
para definir el intervalo del dominio el
valor más pequeño del intervalo llega
hasta 1 2 3 4 y 5 escalones hacia abajo
por lo que en el menos 5 y el valor más
alto es 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 por lo que
n aquí es igual a 10 nuestro rango va de
menos 5 a 10 y se incluyen ambos
extremos así que usaremos corchetes para
incluir este menos 5 si no lo incluyera
pondría paréntesis en lugar de corchetes
voy a usar corchetes aquí y corchetes
acá también